[Music]
[Applause]
okay you look so hot mentioned has
anybody mentioned you can sing oh thank
you it's funny I got to tell you I just
think singing is the most beautiful art
form and I the idea you can stand up
there and do that is breathtaking oh
well thank you Absolut breath it feels
good probably when you finish a scene
and you're like you feel like you killed
it and it was intense and that's how I
feel I feel very fortunate just to have
it as an outlet as well yeah yeah yeah
like a release um no but you had a great
last year so how is 20124 treating you
so far so good I flew to New York City
and it's snowing I know blanket of snow
at Central Park it's very nice nice the
traffic wasn't nice yeah no it's all
good you CU usually I walk and the one
day I choose not to walk we yeah I was
like oh it took an hour and by the way
this is this is the new like I no no but
I'm surprised like somebody hasn't made
like that you know how everybody wears
you know everybody wears earphones yeah
yeah yeah you know and I'm just always
like really really does people like walk
around with earphones cuz I think they
think it makes them look like they like
a rapper or something because I want my
playlist no I want what I'm saying is I
know you have a big playlist and I added
to it but but like a jewelry designer
should make like a larette like with
some precious cuz it's kind of cool like
I'm going get one so just for when you
see a picture like a paparazzi picture
I'm going to be wearing I'm I am
actually shocked though I'm shocked that
they haven't come out with these to like
sell them cuz they are it's the best way
no but but it also just kind of looks
Chic oh well thank you you're welcome
that's what I was going for um well we
mentioned Awards uh because you killed
it the Oscars uh genely posted this
photo last year at the Golden Globes oh
yes first of all no no from this from
this photo alone we could be friends
like that is my level of energy so the
thing that was amazing about the moment
is this is about Michelle yeah and I
love her and it was a really important
moment for her and it began uh what
became obviously a great year for the
movie and Michelle in particular um and
remember this is a woman who's 60 years
old who's been doing this for a long
time yeah and that was a big moment and
what happened from that moment was that
a a a meme a woman named Aaron Gallagher
on social media on social media posted
what she felt from the picture I mean I
just that wasn't like I didn't pose for
that picture it's not even a
particularly nice picture of me it looks
like you're at a
game like what well you're not at a
Cowboys game but you're no sorry about
that so sorry everybody but but I'm I'm
in the moment and what she was talking
about was hype women that women need to
Hype other women I think we do that I
think they just don't show that well but
what she was saying this was like a
really evident moment where a woman was
hyping another woman and we as women
need to do more of that and she created
not I didn't I became like the like
unofficial spokesperson she created an
entire movement hyped women so if you
want to go and follow hype women you'll
you'll see that it's just an important
thing for women to do with each other
because there's a difference between the
word support and hype cuz you know
people always say support women I think
that you should have support everyone as
well but I just mean when you say hype
women like hyping is different it's more
of like you're really like an advocate
for them and you are really like you're
wanting them to get their flowers like
you're it's an energy and you know uh
the world is difficult and we all need
to support each other and so um
especially those huge moments you said
she'd been waiting like years you know
well but it was that it was the
beautiful part of that here's a woman
who I did the movie because Michelle yo
was in it yeah like when they sent me
that weird script believe
me yeah it was a lot going on I did the
movie for two reasons yeah number one
Michelle yo was going to play Evelyn
yeah number two it was shot in Los
Angeles and I live in Los Angeles yeah
and I never work in Los Angeles and so
for me to have a job that was in Los
Angeles I thought was worth doing I had
no idea what it was going to be it was a
little I can't imagine reading that
script like how it played out you know
what I'm saying yeah well all I needed
to know was deardra boardra my character
like I just needed to know her and I I
think we've all met deerra yeah and I'm
not going to say where we've met her
because then because then the haters are
going to come at me and say you made fun
of postal workers and I'm like I didn't
mean it do you know what I mean like
it's awful right now yeah don't go on
the internet don't go on the Internet
it's not safe it can be a scary place
it's a bad place unless you're going for
hype women but we all but we all know
dearra boardra those are people who have
power and they wield that power over you
because you need them to do something
and it's this weird Power Trip and
really what it has to do with is sadness
and loneliness and that's all I needed
to know about dearra was I know her yeah
and so the rest of the movie I wouldn't
have told if you had asked me when we
were making it what's this movie about
I'd be
like but but by the way but the last
scene that I shot or one of the last
scenes I shot was the
reunification between U Michelle and key
in the laundromat and when I saw that
and the daughter I went oh it's about
love honestly the very last moment is
whenever I was like there we go it's
about love and that's when I went oh
yeah but still I didn't know it was
going to become what it became yeah
new children's book is called just one
more sleep so you I we're going to get
to the book but I hear that you're also
very passionate about concerts like live
concerts I am all for this I hear that
you want to start up matinees for
concerts okay here's what I want to say
the
Boomers I am let me just say something
I'm 65 years old and Mommy goes a bit
early so my point is simply this I don't
understand why and I always use
them Cold Play why don't they do a
mattina like a 1:00
concert wouldn't you go to a even a four
even a four I'm down for a
four stop what time did you just say or
four four a concert is usually is like
I'm getting in my pajamas
my you four is
like sleep foreplay sleep
like it's like the before the sleep I am
down for a one as well I'm just telling
you the world is populated by Boomers
we're all going to die soon and it would
be nice to go to a concert again I love
music I live for music but I'm not going
to go to a thing that starts at like I
apparently you did a concert in Vegas
and you started at 9:30 no no no wait
wait wait no here's the thing no I did
not no I did not no I did not you know
when I started 8:30 ma'am and here
here's the thing I they asked
me38 they asked me I'm playing I'm
playing a New Year's Eve thing and
literally they gave me the option of
well do you want to be on stage when it
goes midnight or would you rather do
like your normal 8:30 and I was like it
is there a world in which someone
chooses to be singing at midnight I
don't understand it like I was yeah I'm
I'm forat name I'm just well whatever
I'm starting a movie join me I would
love
to love that I love it I love it so wait
let's talk about the new kids this is
your 13th one right yes so where's this
idea how do you my new book just one
more sleep good things come to those who
wait and wait and wait it's a book about
patience for young children and adults
May and adults um it was born on
Christmas Eve 2020 the covid Christmas
first covid Christmas and you know we
were all terrified and M that Christmas
album Sorry Christmas and I went out to
get my mail on the street and my
neighbor Betty and her mom were in front
of my house we were like 10t away masked
hey Betty hey Jamie I said hey it's
Christmas Eve I said Santa's on his way
and she went like this no Jamie no one
more sleep then Santa and I went oh
right young children metabolize time
yeah through how many sleeps and then
you think about holidays birthdays first
day of school fourth of July Easter
whatever whatever religious holiday or
national holiday Halloween how many kids
are waiting for months for Halloween so
then it helps them metabolize time and
it's funny and it's a sort of
celebration of celebrations and it's
wonderful book for young children so if
you have a young child in your life it's
a new book every parent will get that
they'll see the title and go oh my God
my going to love because that's what
they like I was on a plane I'm not going
to name her an actress was coming back
from I guess the goal no from The
critic's Choice Awards we were on a
flight from LA to New York yeah and she
I told her about the book she said
that's what I said to my children last
night one more sleep than Mommy comes
home and so I do understand that in this
modern world it wasn't when I was you
know uh not when my kids were little but
now with little kids that's how they
metabolize time I know it's interesting
interesting and they do it all on their
own nobody it's a book for children yeah
I love it I so many and they're so good
but I I want to say also you're such a
great Advocate um and you just were
honored by the advocate actually for I
was I was their Cover Girl yeah I love
that though that's such a proud moment I
out of all look up okay that picture is
very hot you're a very rock and roll man
um but where where does your passion
come for well um my youngest daughter
Ruby is trans and
that was a two year ago three year ago
beginning of that part of her life in
our family yeah and for a
parent what's crucial is that you are a
student that you love your child you
want to learn how to help and support
and believe me I get it wrong
occasionally not So Much Anymore and so
it's simply a process of that to me
advocating is listening and loving
that's like the combo of what the word
advocate means is to listen and love and
then if you're a public person share so
that other people can learn and listen
and love have this massive Spotlight
yeah yeah and it's the way to take
advantage of Fame which is you know
Wonderful obviously there are benefits
to it but you know you do give up a lot
of your private life but then you also
have an ability to reach people and so
I've tried to trade off yeah um to reach
people with the work I do that's awesome
probably means a lot to I hope so I mean
that's again it's it's you know you're a
parent you you're never going to know
until I think we're dead and then we're
like oh I really miss my mom like it's
like so you know I'm won't miss anything
though when we're dead we're just
dead Okay picture book is called just
one more sleep it's Jamie's 13th
children's book and like many children's
books it deals with some of the first
moments in a person's life so we thought
we would talk about our first within a
segment and this is a daytime show this
is a daytime show called we're going to
keep it family we're going to keep it
family well B that's how you get a
family if you know what I mean oh so
many jokes um so many jokes yes title of
my
autobiography so many jokes dot dot dot
all right well this is called firsts of
all uh
there first of all yes we have a theme
song We very ENT there's a theme S have
a theme song every moment in life should
have a theme song that's what we say yes
you have a theme song for this and you
know what's so funny is they just wrote
it literally two seconds ago in the
break God bless you people they're very
talented um okay let's see what first
our supercomputer has loaded up for us
to talk about here we go boom Oh my God
what is happening it's very aggressive
it's very oh no this is like oh oh first
kiss oh easy Douglas Ward sixth grade we
jumped off the wall at Betty Wyman's
house and we kissed
midair you had a flying first kiss I did
sixth grade mine
sucked it was not good I'm not going to
say his name cuz that would be mean but
it was horrible it was like he was
searching for something with his
tongue that was the first time yeah no I
had literally never I I mean other than
like you know a PEC on stage in like
musical theater I didn't count that all
right here we go oh God the Box
again oh first celebrity crush stepen
Tyler
wow I was like I had so many
dreams I had daddy
issues wow
I didn't know this was my show and then
we were going to get into all of your
dad issues on National Television you're
welcome thank you there's songs about it
it's fine mine was Chris Knight of The
Brady Bunch he was look
at he seems sweet sweet and cute and
like the middle child I don't know what
do you want I liked him wild yeah okay
wow it's a problem can I single you can
hit it now h
[Applause]
[Music]
yes first oh first book that changed
your life
Matilda I I thought I and what I got
from that wasn't just the magical
element I got from it when I was a kid I
I literally saw this and I very young
age fourth fifth grade and I was like
okay you can be born into something and
climb out of it and that's what I got
from that when I was like you can get
out of you know you can change your
future and I thought that was magical I
thought that was was a really great book
it Is Magical yeah um and yeah it is a
great you Chang your and I did yes
congratulations yeah congratulations
Yeah by that book people um my book uh
was go Dog go oh it was a PD Eastman
early Reader book it was about opposites
you know Big Dog little dog in out I
read my kids yeah but then in the middle
of the book cuz you said like I can
crack wise in the middle of that book
two dogs run into each other and one of
them looks at the other and says hello
hello do you like my
hat the other one says no I do not like
that hat goodbye
goodbye like I thought
wait what and then you know two-thirds
of the way through the book hello again
oh hello do you like my hat no I do not
like that and then at the end of the
book they run into each other and
there's a big party big dog party and
then at the end of the book big
elaborate hat hello again oh hello do
you like my hat yes I do I do like that
party hat goodbye goodbye I'm telling
you some the non
sequer of do you like my
hat made me laugh I don't know why it
just made me laugh and it has stuck with
me my whole life I think that's why I
crack wise because like do you like my
hat yeah but also I like that there's
truth in that we always teach especially
kids in the South we growing up you're
not allowed to say that you don't like
so you're not allow that's impolite so
you have to you're like groomed to
always be polite I see but really you're
just grooming Liars right like like
really we're just all lying that's weird
I agree with you 100% you don't have to
like everything there it made no sense
to me and I think the no sense part is
what really got in my head it's just a r
it's like it's well now you guys say the
word basic all the time but it like
random it's just the random question
that make that has nothing to do with
opposites yes that I just thought was
hilarious yeah like
hilarious changed your life am I am I
done with the game you are done you have
press the
button everybody give it up one more
time for Jamie Lee ctis y' her new
children's book is called just one more
sleep all good things come to those who
wait and wait and wait everyone I have
to do it every time and everyone here is
going home with a
[Music]
[Applause]
copy thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home